hey schön dass ihr dabei seid ZDF heute
live ein winterschutzschirm will die
Deutsche Außenministerin um die Ukraine
spannen dazu hat sie noch einmal während
des NATO ukrainerats aufgefordert helfen
will sie unter anderem mit
Flugabwehrsystem und Stromgeneratoren
denn nach dem letzten Kriegswinter weiß
auch der Westen was die Ukraine wohl
wieder zu erleiden hat Russland greift
gezielt die Energieinfrastruktur an will
dass die Ukraine nicht heizen kein Licht
machen nicht leben kann die ersten
Schneestürme die gab es bereits Anfang
der Woche besonders im Süden wie in
Odessa was wir hier auch jetzt in den
Bildern zeigen können und die Kälte hat
natürlich auch Auswirkung auf die Front
deshalb ist das Thema heute bei uns wie
Russland den Winter nutzt das wollen wir
mit euch diskutieren ihr könnt dazu
Fragen stellen direkt im Stream oder
auch per Mail und wir können sprechen
gich mit Franz steefan gad mit dem wir
darüber diskutieren können erst
militäranalyst am Institute for
international strategic studies in
London er ist Reserveoffizier beim
österreichischen Bundesheer machen ein
kleinen Einspieler hier ein paar Bilder
von ihm vorbereitet er berät Regierung
und Streitkräfte in Europa und den
Vereinigten Staaten unter anderem zur
Zukunft der Kriegsführung und er war
mehrmals in der Ukraine wo er auch die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte bei
verschiedenen zen schon begleitet hat
und Franz Stefan gadi ist jetzt bei uns
schön dass Sie da sind
hallo guten
Abend wir haben eben gerade schon
angesprochen auch Bilder schon gesehen
von jetzt dem Wintereinbruch den es in
der Ukraine besonders im Süden gab also
Eis und Kälte bringt wahrscheinlich auch
eine veränderte Lage an die Front wie
gehen die russischen und die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte damit
um ich GLB das Wichtigste zu verstehen
in h sich der Winterbedingungen im
Moment in lang der Frontlinie des Regens
des Schnees und so weiter ist das es den
Einsatz von Drohnen auf beiden Seiten
erheblicher Schwert bzw reduziert und
das hat unmittelbare Wirkungen auf das
Tempo das Kampfgeschehen an sich es ist
nach wie vor ein Artillerie dominierter
Krieg und Drohnen werden V allem
benötigt eben zur Zielerkennung zur
Zielerfassung und in der Hinsicht können
wir mit einer reduzierten Feuerrate der
Artillerie Rechnung und gleich tig auch
einen reduzierten Einsatz von
sogenannten FPV first person few drohen
also improvisierten kamikaz drohen
rechnen das ist der unmittelbare
also die unmittelbare Konsequenz eben
dieses Wintereinbruches würde ich sagen
jetzt im Moment entlang der Frontlinie
es mehren sich auch die Meldungen über
eine besonders schwierige Lage für die
ukrainischen Soldaten aktuell entlang
der Frontlinie wieso profitiert Russland
insbesondere jetzt vielleicht auch von
eben dem Winter von dem
Kälteeinbruch
ich würde nicht sagen dass Russland
profitiert ich glaube beide Seiten sind
gleich betroffen von den
Wetterbedingungen den winterlichen
Verhältnissen entlang der Frontlinie ich
glaube der Grund warum wir jetzt
womöglich denken dass Russland mehr
Initiative an der Front zeigt an
zumindest Teilen der Front ist
weil letztendlich die ukrainische
Gegenoffensive vor ein paar Wochen
kulminiert ist das heißt sie hat ihren
Höhepunkt überschritten die Ukraine muss
sukzessive jetzt in die defensiv wir
übergehen und die Russen versuchen das
selbstverständlich auszunüzen daher auch
dieses Bild eben dass die Russen jetzt
diese winterlichen Bedingungen ausnutzen
können aber im Großen und Ganzen
betrifft es beide Seiten gleichzeitig
gleich viel ja wir haben direkt auch
eine Frage aus dem Stream an sie kommt
von einem User nennt sich Tom Tom Tom
wie genau beeinflussen schwere
Schneefälle vorhandene Minenfelder die
Räumung von Minenfeldern und die
Neuverlegung von Minenfeldern auf dem
Schlachtfeld das macht es natürlich
schwieriger s sowie das Verlegen als
auch die Räumung von minenfäern mit
neuschnitt selbstverständlich es er
Schwert
diese Art eben der militärischen
Operation bringt es aber jetzt nicht
komplett zum Stillstand das heißt also
das Wetter an sich ist ein Faktor es ist
aber nicht der entscheidende Faktor und
das ist glaube ich ganz wichtig hier
mitzunehmen die Bedingungen sind
schwerer für Angriffe aber auch
für die Verteidigung es hängt natürlich
auch davon ab was genau jetzt der die
wirien Bedingungen sind entlang der
Front bei Schnee und Schlamm ich komme
ja gerade wieder aus der Ukraine ist es
äh so eben dass das oft die Offensive
erschwert bzw wden wirklich der Boden
friert und wirklich ganz ganz
durchfriert dann ist es so dass das
ausgenutzt werden kann für
Offensivkräfte aber dem muss man
selbstverständlich auch gegenüberstellen
wie eben der
her jetztte gemeint hat eben dass es
natürlich einzelne Teile eben eines
Angriffs erschwert wie z.B die Räumung
von min Fällen und wie kann der Winter
jetzt dann genutzt werden wenn wir jetzt
nicht von Profiteuren sprechen aber wie
kann man ihn
nutzen ich glaube für die Ukraine ist es
enorm wichtig dass wie ich bereits
erwähnte Sie entlang der Frontlinie im
Großen und Ganzen in die Defensive
übergeht sich eingräbt das heißt also
tiefere und gestaffelte
Verteidigungsanlagen aufbaut
bzw befestigt und dann gleichzeitig die
Zeit nutzt in der während dieser
defensivstrategie die über den Winter
womöglich durchgeführt wird um
umzugruppieren um Einheiten entlang der
Front zu rotieren das heißt also
Einheiten in die Etappe zu schicken neue
Einheiten an die Front zu schicken die
Truppen auszubilden und langsam eben
neue Kampfkraft zu generieren für Weige
größere Operationen im nächsten Jahr
wobei ich sagen muss wir sollten
erwarten dass die Ukraine für längere
Zeit vielleicht in der Defensive bleiben
wird nach dieser Großoffensive nach
dieser Gegenoffensive im Sommer und im
Herbst und Russland wird wahrscheinlich
da das jetzt versuchen was Russland
bereits im letzten Winter versucht hat
das ist früher oder später
eine neue größere Offensive zu staten
und hier können wir die Ansätze ja schon
entlang einzelner Frontabschnitte
erkennen wobei der große Unterschied
eben im Vergleich zum letzten Winter ist
wenn Sie sich erinnern können im letzten
Winter gab es abrupt eigentlich ein
Strategiewechsel in der russischen äh
Strategie weil eben der Oberkommandeur
auch ersetzt wurde general surokin also
der Mann der eigentlich eine
defensivstategie durchführen wollte über
den letzten Winter den Winter von 2022
auf 2023 und die sogenannte surowikin
Linie errichten lie das heißt also
dieses tief gestaffelte Netz an
Verteidigungsstellungen an dem sich die
ukrainischen Soldaten jetzt im Sommer
und im
Herbst die Zähne sozusagen ausgebissen
haben wurde eben ersetzt dieser general
wikin eben mit General karassimow der
nicht lange gewartet hat und relativ
bald in eine offensive übergegangen ist
und dieses Offensive war eigentlich ein
großes Glück am für die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte weil sie die russischen
Streitkräfte abgenutzt haben
selbstverständlich wurden die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte gleichzeitig
im letzten Winter auch abgenützt
in der Verteidigung der Stadt bachmut
hier gab es große Verluste auf
ukrainischer Seiten und ich glaub die
große Angst jetzt da auf ukrainischer
Seite ist ob es vielleicht über den
Winter zu einem zweiten bachmut kommen
könnte wo eben die ukrainischen
streitkräf Kräfte nach und nach
aufgerieben werden und hier kann ich nur
das Stichwort auf diefka die Stadt eben
die
bedroht ist vor der Einschließung
erwähnen
über diese Stadt werden wir auch gleich
mit unserem Reporter vor Ort sprechen
können mit Tim Kröger der war nämlich
dort ich möchte noch eine frage vorher
kurz noch an Sie stellen die passt
nämlich jetzt auch hier an dieser Stelle
noch gut sie haben eben gerade davon
gesprochen dass die Sorge besteht dass
wieenbachmut die Soldaten aufgerieben
werden könnten um das vielleicht zu
verhindern könnte man natürlich auch
Soldaten auswechseln aber das würde sie
vermutlich dann auch viel angreifbarer
machen auf dem Feld
oder nein ich glaube was sie mit
auswechseln äh ansprechen das meine ich
mit den äh Truppen durchzurotieren eben
das heißt den Truppen ausz rauszulösen
eben und durch neue zu ersetzen hier
muss man sagen eben und das kann ich
auch jetzt bestätigen durch meineen
letzten frontbesuche eben vor einigen
Wochen eben ist es sehr schwierig
einzelne Einheiten zu rotieren eben weil
es auf beiden Seiten auf russischer und
auf ukrainischer Seite natürlich
Personalmangel gibt beide Seiten sind
relativ verbraucht beide Seiten brauchen
eigentlich die Zeit zur Regeneration
auch und
ähm in der Hinsicht wäre es
begrüßenswert eben wenn einzelne
Einheiten rausgelöst werden können vor
allem die Infanterie die kämpfende
Truppe sozusagen unter Anführungszeichen
wie sie militärjargon heißt also die
Truppe die dann wirklich Angriffe
durchführt die sind relativ verbraucht
und
die Angriffe die wir vor paar Wochen
noch observieren konnten eben entlang
der Frontlinie sind im Moment auf
Gruppenrahmen zusammengeschrumpft also
hier werden Angriffe nicht einmal mehr
im zugrahmen durchgeführt od im Halbzug
also hier handelt es sich um Angriffen
mit um Angriffe mit ungefähr 16 Mann 12
Mann und so weiter und nicht mehr 30 35
40 und gar nicht kompagniahmen also 100
200 Mann oder sogar bataallonsrahmen ja
batalonsangriffe haben wir im
allgemeinen wirklich nicht observieren
können über die letzten Monate hier gab
es ein Ansitze auf russischer Seite aber
dennoch ist es so eben dass die Truppen
auf beiden Seiten relativ verbraucht
sind und dringend Ruhe auch benötigen
wir sprechen gleich weiter wollen jetzt
aber an dieser Stelle noch mal ein
bisschen in die Tiefe gehen wie es den
Soldaten an der Front geht den müden und
erschöpften Soldaten die auch vom
Präsidenten von Präsident selenski
besucht worden sind er will die
Motivation der Truppe hochhalten war
also am Donnerstag auf Truppenbesuch in
kupjansk in der Region hakif die Stadt
kupjansk wurde im September 2022 aus
russischer Besatzung befreit doch in den
letzten Monaten hat Russland dort wieder
Geländegewinne gemacht die Soldaten die
dort nun also schon seit vielen Monaten
heftige Kämpfe führen müssen erschöpft
sein klar und wir können jetzt darüber
sprechen ich habe schon angekündigt mit
unserem Reporter live für uns in der
Ukraine ist Tim Kröger wir erreichen ihn
im Donbass hallo Tim schön dass du bei
uns
bist schönen guten Abend Tim ihr wart in
den letzten Tagen im Osten unterwegs du
bist auch z Zeit noch im Osten ihr
konntet auch mit Soldaten reden was
haben sie dir erzählt wie ist es zu
Kämpfen in dieser zermirbenden Lage
aktuell also zuerstmal war es
beeindruckend dass uns die Soldaten
immer noch erzählen dass sie nach wie
vor motiviert sind in diesen Kämpfen
aber natürlich haben sie uns auch
erzählt dass sie mittlerweile nach fast
zwei Jahren Krieg wirklich sehr sehr
erschöpft sind das kann man ja auch
verstehen wir haben es gerade eben schon
gehört viele von diesen Soldaten sind
seit den ersten Kriegswochen nach dem 24
Februar 2022 an der Front es gibt kaum
Rotation das heißt viele Soldaten kommen
kaum
auf Urlaub nach Hause also das scheint
schon sehr zermürbend zu sein die
Soldaten haben uns aber auch erzählt
dass vor allem auch die Familien sehr
darunter leiden unter diesen langen
Zeiten die die Soldaten vorne an der
Front stehen es fehlen natürlich die
Partner im Alltag aber es ist natürlich
auch die permanente Angst die die
Familien um die Soldaten haben also ob
sie den nächsten Tag noch überstehen
die Soldaten mit denen wir gesprochen
haben haben vor allem gekämpft in der
eben schon angesprochenen Stadt afdfka
hier im donbas das ist ja im Moment so
die Stadt die eigentlich am
allerhärtesten umkämpft worden ist und
die Soldaten haben uns erzählt dass die
Situation der ukrainischen Armee dort
relativ schwierig ist das liegt zum
einen daran dass der ukrainischen Armee
Waffen und Munition fehlen das ist aber
auch vor allem deshalb so weil die
russischen Streitkräfte wirklich
versuchen mit tausenden Soldaten seit
Oktober versuchen diese Stadt wirklich
unter hohen Verlusten also um jeden
Preis einzunehmen sie versuchen diese
Stadt einzukesseln von Norden und von
Süden und ganz offenbar ist das so
dass der Grund für dieses massive
Vorgehen seit Oktober ist dass der
russische Präsident Putin Erfolge
braucht vor den russischen Wahlen die ja
anstehen ähm afdka ist schon immer eine
Frontstadt gewesen
ist schon immer stark umkämpft gewesen
aber wie gesagt jetzt seit wenigen
Wochen gibt es dort noch mal eine vi
wesentlich heftigere Offensive und ein
Soldat hat uns sogar erzählt dass er das
Empfinden hat dass dieser Kampf um afdka
sogar noch einmal heftiger ist als der
in bachmut also das zeigt ungefähr wie
schwierig die in einer was für
schwierigen Lage die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte dort in nadka sind du warst
dort eben ganz in der Nähe unterwegs
hast eben auch eine Polizeieinheit
getroffen wir können auch gleich Bilder
davon zeigen was hast Du erlebt
genau das ist eine polizeieineit die
mehr oder weniger aus zwei Männern
besteht die beide auch selber aus afdfka
kommen diese beiden Männer fahren in
einem gepanzerten ja ich würde sagen
Lieferwagen jeden Tag mehr oder weniger
jeden Tag nachdfk rein bringen
Hilfsgüter rein bringen auf der anderen
Seite Menschen raus also retten sie wenn
es zu viel Beschuss gibt und wir konnten
sie selber leider nicht begleiten nach
afdfka aber sie haben mit einer kleinen
Kamera Bilder gedreht und haben sie uns
gezeigt und
was da zu sehen ist ist wirklich wie
stark aufdka zerstört ist wie gesagt
afdka wird schon lange umkämpft und die
Menschen aus der Stadt haben uns erzählt
dass im Grunde kein Tag im Moment
vergeht ohne dass wirklich diese Stadt
heftigst beschossen wird es gibt auch
eine Situation wo diese bei diese
Polizeieinheit dann eben das einzig noch
arbeitende Krankenhaus in der Stadt
versorgt mit Diesel für die Generatoren
unter anderem auch mit Gas damit das
Krankenhaus weiter funktioniert also das
tun sie unter Einsatz ihres Lebens und
kommen dann eben nach mehreren Stunden
abends dann aus dieser Stadt wieder raus
und riskieren dann im Grunde ja jeden
Tag ihr Leben also das war schon sehr
beeindruckend diese beiden Männer da
kennenzulernen insbesondere eben
erbitterter Kampf um aufwka du hast es
uns geschildert aber natürlich klar im
ganzen Donbass insbesondere auch in der
Region donjzk immer wieder Angriffe so
gab es eben jetzt auch letzte Nacht
Angriffe mit Raketen auf einen Ort auf
mehrere Ort en in der Region mindestens
ein Mensch ist dabei gestorben sind das
intensivere Angriffe in den letzten
Tagen oder tatsächlich so der
Alltag also schwere Angriffe auch mit
schweren Raketen das ist im donmarß
nichts neues das hat es schon immer
gegeben in den vergangenen anderthalb
bis zwei Jahren aber jetzt in den
jüngsten Tagen war das schon noch mal
bemerkenswert es waren ja
6s300 Raketen die da auf verschiedene
Orte im Donbass niedergegangen sind sind
du hast es gesagt dabei ist ein Mensch
ums Leben gekommen mindestens ein Mensch
mehrere wurden verletzt also ja das ist
schon eine Intensivierung vor allem sind
alle diese Ortschaften nicht unweit von
der eben schon angesprochenen Stadt
abdfka das könnte eben ein Zeichen sein
dass ich diese Kämpfe in um und auch
außerhalb von fdfk noch einmal
verschafen die Einschätzung live von Tim
Kröger aus der Ukraine in der Region Don
jetzt danke dir
Tim und wir können jetzt hier wieder
weiter sprechen mit dem militäranalyst
den wir uns eingeladen haben Franz
Stefan gadidi ist wieder bei uns schön
dass sie wieder da sind sie haben gerade
mit zugehört haben gehört was unser
Reporter geschildert hat was hat die
Ukraine aktuell wie in diesem heftigen
Kampf um avdevka Russland noch
entgegenzusetzen nun also ich finde es
beeindruckend was ihr Reporter hier
berichtet hat und vielleicht möchte ich
den Zuhörerinnen und zuhörerern mal hier
vermittel nehmen was es wirklich
bedeutet in einem artilleriekrieg
verwickelt zu sein bzw dort an der Front
zu sein und äh das äh Artillerie Feuer
permanent im zu hören und vor allem auch
exponiert zu sein
äh gegenüber eben diesen Einschlägen und
bzw auch die ewige Furcht die man hat
eben dass man vielleicht getroffen wird
es ist ein schrecklich passives passives
Gefühl eben äh russischen
Artilleriefeuer ausgeliefert zu sein sei
es jetzt rohrartillerie oder
raketenartillerie und ähm der
psychologische Druck auf die einzelnen
Soldaten ist enorm und ich kann nur
persönliche Erfahrung sagen wenn man
dann wirklich me einer befestigten
Stellung ist in einem Bunker ähm fühlt
es sich sehr
erleichternd an wenn man quasi unter der
Erde liegt und zumindest etwas Schutz
hat und man geht die ganze Zeit mit dem
Gefühl umher das kann man vielleicht
vergleichen mit den Sekunden bevor man
einen Schlag ins Gesicht erwartet ja
also man ist körperlich extremst
angespannt und denken Sie sich jetzt da
dass Soldaten hier Monate jahreel lang
schon also diesen Druck ausgesetzt sind
also was das langfristig mit den
Soldaten macht
wage ich hier gar nicht mehr
vorzustellen um jetzt auf Ihre Frage
einzugehen auf jeevka ja also hier ist
das große Problem selbstverständlich
dass die Truppen in der Stadt selbst
früher oder später vielleicht
abgeschnitten werden können bzw eben
dass es zu einer Art Festung auf dieevka
kommt eben wo die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte hier langsam ausgeblutet
werden wohl selbstverständlich die
Russen wie bereits erwähnt große
Verluste haben mein persönlicher
sorgenis oder warum ich mir Sorgen mache
was diese Entwicklung betrifft ist nicht
so sehr die Stadt selbst sondern was
kommt danach und ob die ukrainischen
Streitkräfte sich hinter afevka ja
einkramen können bzw hier relativ
schnell jetzt eine neue
Verteidigungslinie hochziehen können
können bzw hier eben ein gestaffelt das
Verteidigungssystem etablieren das ist
enorm wichtig wenn auf die FK verloren
geht führt es zu einer Begradigung der
Front es wird jetzt keinen unmittelbar
strategischen Einfluss haben auf das
Kampfgeschehen
bzw wird es auch nicht so sein dass es
jetzt nennen ein nennenswerter Erfolg
wäre für die russischen Streitkräfte
zumindest wäre es ein sehr teuer
erkaufter ervolk aber langfristig ist es
so eben die ist es wichtig dass die
Ukraine hier die Verteidigungsstellungen
etabliert eben um die Stadt sollte sie
verloren gehen um den also die Einnahme
der Stadt den den den den russischen
vormarch hier etwas eindämmern zu können
es gibt aber auch andere Sektoren eben
wo die Russen großen Druck erhöhen z.B
im Bereich kupiansk
dort in der Gegend und
hier ist es auch so eben dass die
Ukraine wahrscheinlich sich es sehr
schwer tut im Moment Reserven zu
verschieben es sind nicht mehr genügend
Reserven auch vorhanden auf ukrainischer
Seite und Russland selbstverständlich
kämpft hat auch Personalprobleme das
möchte ich ja nicht kinreen aber beide
Seiten wie gesagt sind relativ erschöpft
es gibt aber größeren offensiven Druck
im Moment von Russland und das letzten
Punkt möchte ich vielleicht hier
erwähnen Russland in den nächsten Monat
hat mit Sicherheit in drei Bereichen
einen Vorteil zumindest äh was die
Quantität betrifft erstens was artilleri
Munition betrifft das ist sehr
signifikant weil es nach wie vor ein
artillari dominierter Krieg ist zweitens
was FPV drohen also selbstgebaute
kamikaz Dronen betrifft hier hat
Russland einen Vorteil das ist natürlich
auch jetzt der relativ ähm ja von
Vorteil für das unmittelbare
Kampfgeschehen und drittens im Bereich
elektronische Kampfführung ist es äh hat
Russland hier einen Vorteil und
elektronische Kriegsführung also das
heißt jetzt Störsender und so weiter die
eben angreifende drohen ablenken können
bzw die eben die Verbindung unterbringen
unterbrechen können eben von Drohnen
hier ist es natürlich so dass je mehr
drohen auf dem Schlachtfeld eingesetzt
werden desto wichtiger die elektronische
Kampfführung her ist und ich glaube im
Vergleich jetzt zu einen meiner
vorherigen frontbesuchen ist es so dass
ich am meisten das wahrgenommen hat die
Präsenz eben von diesen FBV drohen die
wirklich überall sind und ähm die
ständig im Einsatz sind schauen wir mal
auf einen Bereich wir haben auch eine
Karte vorbereitet wo es für die
ukrainischen Truppen vorangegangen ist
wir schauen jetzt in die Region herson
denn dort sollen die ukrainischen
Truppen Brückenköpfe am nipro am Fluss
errichtet haben während also Russland
von Umgruppierungen spricht aber klar da
gibt's natürlich unterschiedliche
narrative in diesem Krieg aber die große
Frage die das natürlich bedeutet wenn
dort die Truppen vorrücken und da kommt
nämlich eine Frage aus dem Stream dazu
was wie das einzuordnen ist was das
bedeuten könnte als Erfolg für die
Ukraine und zwar möchte Stefan warenberg
bei Youtube gerne wissen wie realistisch
ist es dass die Ukraine in der Region
Cherson ab dem kommenden Frühling bis
zur Krim sogar vortringen
kann also soweit kann ich jetzt die Lage
nicht äh Voraussagen selbstverständlich
ich möchte ein paar Punkte erwähnen
erstens erfolgte dieser Vorstoß nachdem
die ukrainische Gegenoffensive bereits
kulminierte es gibt also keine
unterstützungsachse für offensive
Operationen im militärischen äh in
militärischen Unternehmungen braucht man
eine unterstützungsachse um eben nicht
äh den Gegner dazu äh veranlassen dass
er eben seine Reserven alle in diese
eine Richtung eben wo e dieser
Brückenkopf jetzt entsteht entsenden
kann das ist also extrem schwierig im
Moment fürukinischen Streitkräfte hier
auszubrechen weil es eben diese
unterstützungsaktie nicht gibt dann
reden wir hier von kleineren
Gruppierungen ukrainischer Soldaten also
vielleicht mehreren hundert und
die auch jetzt dann nicht über das
notwendige Gerät für einen größeren
Durchbruch verfügen dann ist die
Versorgungslage im Winter natürlich eine
ganz andere die Anforderungen eben für
den Nachschub ein ganz anderer als im
Sommer dann sind die
Witterungsbedingungen eben Regen Schnee
und so weiter ers schwerenis den
Soldaten auch hier durchzuhalten also
ich glaube man muss realistisch sein was
dieser Vorstoß hier reichen kann es ist
eine limitierte Operation würde ich
sagen die jetzt ja keinen großen
strategischen Einfluss auf das
Kriegsgeschehen bzw den Frontverlauf in
unmittelbarer Zukunft eben unmittelbarer
Zukunft ausüben wird sie haben gerade
die Versorgung angesprochen können Sie
das uns noch mal ein bisschen
detaillierter aufzeigen was ein kalter
Winter ein frostiger Winter Schneestürme
was das auch alles für Auswirkung auf
die Versorgung haben
könnten nun die
Witterungsverhältnisse haben
Auswirkungen auf die Munition z.B auf
ähm die ein gepanzerten Fahrzeuge auf
die Motoren m auf die Erhaltung der
Kampfkraft also ist es denn Soldaten
warm haben die Soldaten genug Öfen und
so weiter
ist es trocken genug in den einzelnen
Cremen ist es wirklich so eben dass es
den ganzen Winter über überschneiden
wird oder bleibt es eben sehr nass hier
gibt es verschiedenste Faktoren und ist
es so dass viel bewölkt ist das
limitiert dann auch den Einsatz z.B von
Drohnen auf beiden Seiten und so weiter
also hier gibt es dutzende dutzende
Faktoren die wichtig sind aber ich
möchte das immer jetzt wirklich im
Kontext wissen das heißt also die
Wetterbedingungen sind ein Faktor aber
sicher nicht der entscheidende Faktor in
diesem Krieg und das hat auch ja das
letzte Jahr gezeigt sie dürfen nicht
vergessen dass die russischen
Streitkräfte im Winter in die Offensive
übergegangen sind und
m dass auch die Ukraine relativ lange
angegriffen hat in dieser Gegenoffensive
wo schon die Schlammperiode im äh
begonnen hatte in der Ukraine und ich
war ja selbst an der Front während
dieser schlamperiode und wenn man hier
wirklich mit Rad
Panzern bzw mit gepanzerten Fahrzeugen
mit redern und einzelnen Fahrzeugen mit
redern fährt und nicht mit Ketten
man bleibt relativ schnell stecken also
es ist wirklich so eben dass man
versinkt fast im Schlamm wenn die Straße
nicht asphaltiert ist also sollte es ein
wärmerer
Winter werden wie im letzten Jahr dann
hat das natürlich unmittelbaren Einfluss
auf die Angriffsoperationen beider
Seiten
es gibt noch eine ja eine sehr große
Frage auf jeden Fall eine eine Frage die
in die Zukunft gerichtet ist aus dem
Stream die ich gerne zum Schluss noch an
Sie stellen möchte natürlich
interessiert das nämlich viele und zwar
stellt sich der User der sich ie nennt
er oder sie die Frage wie schätzen Sie
die Wahrscheinlichkeit ein dass 2024 das
letzte Kriegsjahr sein wird ich weiß es
ist schwer in die Glaskugel zu schauen
aber vielleicht können Sie für uns
zumindest meine Analyse Wagen was es
alles bräuchte für die eine Version und
was passiert in der in der zweiten
Version und ich kann mich hier relativ
kurz halten also beide Seiten glauben
noch genügend militärische Optionen zu
haben es gibt auf russischer Seite kein
einziges Indiz dass
der Kremel bereit wäre zu verhandeln auf
ukrainischer Seite glaube ich würde es
durchaus
ja m einzelne Akteure geben die bereit
wden zumindest Gespräche zu beginnen ja
ob sie dann wirklich
wirklich ehrlich verhandeln wollen sei
äh dahingestellt aber ich glaube beide
Seiten pochen noch auf militärische
Optionen um eben hier äh vielleicht eine
Wende im nächsten
Jahr also zu erreichen aber ich glaube
man muss realistisch sein auf
ukrainischeer Seite sollte das nächste
Jahr zu einem Aufbaujahr für die
ukrainischen Streitkräfte genutzt werden
das heißt also eine defensivstrategie
würde ich hier wahrscheinlich vorziehen
um eben die Kampfkraft zu erhalten bzw
die ischen Streitkräfte aufzubauen
gleichzeitig muss man aber den Druck auf
die russischen Streitkräfte
aufrechterhalten weil wie man mit
afjevka auch sieht wenn zu sehr der
Druck nachläst dann geht gehen die
russischen Truppen auch schnell wieder
in die Offensive über und
ich glaube das Ziel auf russischer Seite
ist nach wie vor in unmittelbarer
Zukunft
m gesamten donbas also die oblasten
donetk und lohansk unter voller
russischer Kontrolle zu bringen
langfristig glaube ich dennoch das das
Ziel des kremels Wladimir Putins nach
wie vor ist die gesamte Ukraine zu
unterjochen das heißt eine proorussische
Regierung dort zu etablieren und ich
glaube von russischer Perspektive sieht
man keinen Grund eben diesen Krieg
frühzeitig hier abzubrechen sie glauben
eben dass langfristig es von Vorteil ist
den Krieg auszudehnen so lang wie nur
möglich und auf ukrainischer Seite ist
glaube ich das große Problem wenn man
auf militärischer Seite sagt wir gehen
in die Defensive könnte es hier
vielleicht zu Spannungen auf der mit der
politischen Ebene E gehen mehr weil die
politische Ebene selbstverständlich auch
Erfolge vorweisen will und das hat mir
auch öffentlich ein bisschen gesehen
dass es auf ukrainischer Seite hier
intern einige Spannungen gab aber ich
glaube das Wichtigste zu verstehen ist
das Jahr 2024 muss ein Aufbaujahr werden
für die ukrainischen Streitkräfte und
die Ukraine würde gut tun
in die Defensive zu gehen obwohl eben
gleichzeitig der Druck aufrechterhalten
bleiben sollte auf die russischen
Streitkräfte aber das muss nicht
unmittelbar eine neue Offensive bedeuten
die Ukraine hat auch nicht die nötig
notwendige Munition nochmals eine
offensive durchzuführen wie sie es jetzt
mit der Gegenoffensive im Sommer und
Herbst getan hat das muss man auch offen
sagen es gibt hier einen Nachteil was
die Artilleriemunition betrifft aber
gleichzeitig gibt es sehr viele neue
indigene Systeme Langstrecken Drohnen
die eben benutzt werden um tiefe
alsoerziele in der Tiefe des russischen
Raums des russisch besetzten Gebietes
anzugreifen und sich auch früher oder
später eben stärker und stärker auf die
Krim zu konzentrieren und hier kann ich
mir gut Vorst D früher oder später eben
einzelne Brücken verstärkt angegriffen
werden einzelne Militärstützpunkte und
so weiter und man wird nach wie vor
versuchen den Druck auf die Krim
aufrecht zuerhalten um den Druck dadurch
auf die russische militärische und
politische Führung sukzessive im Jahr
2024 zu erhöhen und die
munitionssituation auf ukrainischer
Seite wird sich wahrscheinlich
verbessern auch Ende des Jahres was ein
weiterer Punkt werde wäre warum die
Ukraine auch nicht jetzt so schnell
glaub also wahrscheinlich diesen Krieg
beenden wird ein Schätzung von
militäranalyst Franz Stefan gardi vielen
Dank dass Sie bei uns zu Gast
waren danke
SchH wir berichten für euch wie ihr
wisst ja meistens wöchentlich in unserem
militärischen Analyse hier bei ZF heute
live also das wird es auch natürlich
weiter für euch geben wir haben jeden
Tag Reporterinnen und Reporter wie Tim
Kröger in der Ukraine die also für uns
jederzeit bei ZF heute auch berichten
für heute für den Moment für diesen
Ukraine Stream erstmal danke für eure
Aufmerksamkeit und eure Fragen schönen
Abend und
tschüss